[Musik]
wir machen heute aus steckplätzen also
einmal im jahr nicht zum november
dezember ist immer so die zeit wo man
ausstich petzen macht und dann das ganze
jahr über wieder aber man muss es
richtig zelebrieren also machen wir
jetzt den klassischen urteil und dann
suchen muss einfach hübsche vorwand aus
und haben sich dekorieren dann einfach
ein paar hübsche plätzchen nicht ja das
habe ich einfach nur so bestimmt haben
so ist gleich auch mit einem staatlich
fangen direkt an kleiner hinweis an euch
die ganz genauen mengenangaben schreibe
ich euch unter dem titel in die infobox
einfach aufklappen danke durch ein
screenshot machen einkaufen geht aber
meistens hat man die zutaten echt schon
zu hause so ich fange jetzt an gebt mir
mein mail auf die saubere arbeitsfläche
macht euch da einfach ein bisschen platz
es geht natürlich auch alles mit der
küchenmaschine aber ich hab gedacht ich
mache so einfach mit den händen um euch
zu zeigen wie sie das geht so in die
mitte gebe ich dann meine mutter die
habe ich jetzt frisch aus dem
kühlschrank wenn jetzt eine halbe stunde
auf zimmertemperatur ist ach guck mal
ich merke schon hier
dadurch dass wir das hier drehe sich so
ein bisschen verzögert hat wie die
lichter aufgebaut haben sie auch schon
ein bisschen weicher geworden dann kommt
der zucker dazu backpulver 1 1 und dann
mit den händen erschien verkneten
wohin mit dir
so jetzt fehlt natürlich geschmack weil
so ist es natürlich mega langweilig auch
in buttergeschmack sehr lecker ist aber
wir machen das vanille butterplätzchen
dafür haben sie brauche deine hilfe du
bitte mal ein bisschen vanille extrakt
in meinen tag während ich kniete könnte
natürlich auch feuer machen einfach
drauf nach gefühl das ist gefühl einfach
bist denn gefühl dir sagt okay das
reicht ist das weil ich sehr gut
das sind exakt ist sehr konzentriert
deswegen braucht man eigentlich nicht so
viel
naja ok
jetzt habe ich den teig mit den händen
ungefähr zwei minuten geknetet und ihr
merkt dass er fertig ist bin einfach gar
nichts mehr kleben bleibt gestern zum
beispiel hat meine schwester auch noch
ausfällt wie gemacht für mich angerufen
und gesagt eben ein teil klebt total und
er ist so weil ich was soll ich jetzt
machen und sie hat und margarine benutzt
es auch kein problem könnte auch
margarine benutzen
aber wenn er in den kühlschrank kommend
und gekühlt ist ist ja auf jeden fall
besser zu verarbeiten was passiert im
kühlschrank
erstens wird die butter schön hat und
zweitens lösen sich die zuckerkristalle
auf deshalb drücken wir das schön flach
nehmen uns hier frischhaltefolie hoch so
drücken das schön flach wickeln das ein
und dann für 60 minuten in den
kühlschrank was ja auch machen könnt
kleiner tipp ihr könnt es auch am vortag
oder vorm vorbereiten ist also so wirkt
hält tage lang im kühlschrank ihr könnt
ihn sogar einfrieren und dann irgendwann
noch mal kekse machen
also ich will einfach mal danke es
gleich so nach der kür zeit ist der teig
sehr hart und sehr fest und den müssen
wir jetzt ganz kurz mit den händen also
wirklich nur ein paar sekunden
geschmeidig kneten der bricht dann auch
so dass es ganz normal und dann
ausrollen dazu muss ich gleich aber eine
hohe noch was sagen
[Musik]
so jetzt müssen wir den teig relativ
zügig ausrollen der soll er nicht wieder
sehr weich werden durch die zimmer wärme
und es gibt mehrere möglichkeiten
entweder nehmt euch nudelholz ganz
oldschool rollt ihn aus und können dann
einfach aussteller nehmen und den teig
ausstechen
denn nachteil ist dass ihr dann keine
kontrolle habt ob der teig überall
gleichmäßig dick ausgerollt ist und im
ofen braucht dann eigentlich jeder keks
anders lange also einer brauche ein paar
sekunden länger der an renault minute
weniger weil denn eben nicht gleichmäßig
sind und da gibt es halt ganz praktische
helferlein entweder nimmt ihr euch
direkt ein aus rolf starb wohl schon
solche abstanden ringer würde ich sagen
integriert sind dann heute da drüber und
dann irgendwann landete auf der
arbeitsfläche und das sind dann sechs
millimeter also ich persönlich mag seit
fünf bis sechs millimeter dick oder so
mache ich es heute ihr nehmt euch
abstand hölzer die sind jetzt hier 5 mm
dick nimmt die einfach und gibt neben
den der teig auf die bemehlten
arbeitsfläche und dann nimmt ihr euch
euer nudelholz und dann müsst ihr auch
darauf achten dass sie wirklich
irgendwann mit dem nudelholz hier auf
den abstand hölzern landet und dann hat
der teig nämlich auch die gleichmäßige
dicke und ist dann gleichzeitig fertig
im backofen aus über zwei ist zwei
möglichkeiten vielleicht kennt ihr auch
nur dritter dann schreibt es rein es
gibt halt nicht immer die perfekte
lösung
aber man kann sich das wirklich alles
vereinfachen welche technik seien hier
daneben und dann nur 3
[Musik]
also der teig ist ausgerollt und jetzt
nehmt ihr euch auf eurer wahl
spezialfach lahmann einhorn und was
orientalisches und da habe ich auch
einen top tipp für euch einfach den
ausstecher kurz in mehl rhein geben und
dann er bleibt es nämlich nicht mehr
haften dann könnte da rein in den teig
und wieder raus und dann klebt ihr euch
nicht am ausstecher
[Musik]
also gerade so filigran sachen könnt ihr
mit der dünnen palette einmal drunter so
leise ich weiß es nicht
na ja jetzt erst einmal auf
[Musik]
so die plätzchen kommen dann bei 180
grad ober unterhitze in den vorgeheizten
backofen für circa zehn minuten jetzt
habe ich noch einen ganz ganz ganz
entscheidenden tipp für euch falls ihr
lange braucht beim ausrollen ausstechen
und ich besonders viel zeit lässt dann
wird der teig er wieder sehr weich daher
wenn das der fall ist gibt ein backblech
für zehn minuten in den kühlschrank und
dann direkt aus dem kühlschrank in den
vorgeheizten backofen das bewegt dass
der teig dann nicht mehr zerläuft und da
haben wir ihnen die formschön erhalten
bleibt wie zum beispiel hier bei unserem
einhorn nicht auch so und jetzt müssen
wir das ja nur noch schminken und
dekoriert dafür nehmen wir natürlich
streusel sowieso und jetzt habt ihr drei
möglichkeiten wie das verziert entweder
geschmolzene schokolade so geschmerzt
kuvertüre ich bin fan von rising dafür
nehmt ihr euch jetzt ein eiweiß das ei
gebrauchen wenn ich ein frisches ei weiß
macht euch keine sorgen wenn es frisch
ist dann kann da nichts passieren sofern
jetzt nicht gerade schwanger sein so und
da sehe ich da einfach puderzucker
hinein und falls ihr sagt nee das ist
nichts für mich dann machen wir auch
noch eine ganz normale puderzucker
glasur
das kennt ihr glaube ich alle da macht
man auch einfach nur gesiebte
puderzucker mit zitronen sagt hey
[Musik]
so muss die konsistenz sein
und das könnte jetzt auch noch einfärben
das mache ich jetzt auch
[Musik]
aber das belastet mich bloß nicht extra
gemacht ich wollte euch trägern bei mir
nicht ihr könnt nach herzenslust
dekorieren und das ist ein wirklich
entspannter teil also macht es auch
nicht alleine
ihr könnt auch alleine machen aber ich
habe gemerkt ich hab's überwinden
mit kids ich habe mir auch überlegt ob
ich meine schwester oder deine arbeit
ist auch viel zu spät dann beim nächsten
mal oder ich lasse den rest einfach und
der kurier die morgen
ich verabschiede mich zu jetzt schon mal
von euch mit dem hinweis das natürlich
alles in der video beschreibung also
eine infobox schiff von den zutaten bis
hin zu den produkten nicht benutzt habe
auch die streusel etc
aber seht sehen möchte weil ich jetzt
nicht vergessen werdet sehen möchte die
hansa ein plätzchen dekorierte darf
gerne über anschluss dran bleiben
jaha also an alle die mir jetzt
verlassen was gut bis zum nächsten mal
fliege sketchen und jetzt komm ich rüber
und wir tauschen die kamera heute zum
fakt lustig wiesn ist es so gesund man
sieht ja was machen jetzt kommt der
nächste ist ein krieg seiner wahl und
das abrufen
das lama nehmen ich denke da kamen dann
aber als ich das gleiche geld kann man
sich ja gerne amerikaner kam das war
jetzt echt das war jetzt keine gleich
oder so aber das ist unser freund macht
man das so und sie uns aber ich bin
trotzdem vertrauen als er neun verfahren
uns ist es schwierig am ist sie gespannt
was schwierig weil da viele details sind
oder weil sie was kommen muss nur sehen
und yahoo wird sich dieses wissen jetzt
was ganzen also das ganze was ist los
mit dir
was ist los mit dir das ist doch dass
ich mal meinen körper auf die haare
sollten auch eine andere farbe haben
ich wusste ich kann nicht mal ein
strichmännchen
so soll hier das fenster oder jeder dass
er auch andere fahren ist nicht auch
hart also ich weg machen ja finde das
sieht nach sehr schlecht er heftig der
arbeit ich bin es heftig ganz ehrlich ja
was man da was ich kann nicht mehr an
die macht die ganze sache weiß wie
anschaut das ist ja deswegen mich noch
nicht zu rechnen in beiden kammern jetzt
muss es irgendwie naiv aber ich weiß das
genau ist dort ein hort eine aufnahme so
bunt oder so
und die haare machen immer wunderschön
ist ein richtiger punk anfang gekühlt
ich kann mich gerade schlafen haben
berichtet ist das ja so haben wir die
haare heftig richtig schön es ist
einfach nicht ganz richtig cool ich
würde nicht aus
eine start stop start warten also in die
regale weiter exakt was bitte in die
kamera
bitte bitte da fuhren vom 100 ich bleibe
ich an das müsst ihr sehen
ich bin ich nur nach hause gehen
es ist wenn man sticht es so soll s
video von ihr gesehen und für das
ausland
die geschichte ich würde das ist genauso
wand hält damit sie leute wie
anstrengend es ist die lust sich behält
zwar so dass so ein bisschen mehr was
das ist wollte so einen zahnstocher
linklink war doch ein richtig
christophen haben ihr rating für genau
das ist schon gut gelernt gerade in den
zwei minuten ruhig gezeigt ich habe
heute gut wären also du bist mein
sensation
also ganz ehrlich was könnte auch ein
kind gemacht der so wie du es machst du
den winkel palette nehmen können muss
mit der spitze eigentlich so kreisende
bewegung machen
hansa hat die kette an wird er dieses
diesem format 60 sagt man so sagt hierzu
einen kindergarten
es ist schön aber es ist nicht schön
also wenn du zum tanz die mal heran
also ich finds künftig reicht heute ich
es mir wünsche nur sagen
[Musik]